well i grew up in uh
rural western colorado a small
cattle mining and coal mining town and
it was an unusual situation it was a
very poor area
my father was a traveling salesman
and in ordinary circumstances that would
have made us
middle lower middle but because everyone
else had less
money it actually made us like the
wealthiest
folks in town and so it was really a
funny situation but i spent a lot of
time hunting
fossils and being off in the sagebrush
and the
washes looking for fossils and
bird eggs and stuff like that i was a
strange child that's what they always
said about me they used to call me a
little old lady
because i would talk to the rocks and
the
bushes and things yes well i've been
seven
going on 90 for as long as i can
remember
but then you're like me yes psychedelics
don't make that much of a difference to
you then do they
well i don't know i when i think about
what led me to psychedelics i think it
was
quest for beauty and nature first it was
oh i don't know butterflies and then it
was shells and then it was
reef fishes and it was really a quest
for
beauty and the notion of hallucinations
was just magnetic to me i can remember
reading aldous huxley's the doors of
perception and
this notion of hallucinations i just
wanted to have one i couldn't imagine
such a thing i mean i was quite a
sort of a rationalist and i just the
idea of seeing
things which aren't there why who
wouldn't pursue that
it sounds absolutely daft so
you know i did and look where it's taken
me
well by the time i was 9 or 10 i was
a earnest practitioner of ceremonial
magic
and i would draw pentacles in my room
and burden rosemary
and i was also an altar boy at this time
and uh it made some problems
uh i recall one time i don't know how
many of you are
are recovering catholics but uh
there's a thing which they bring out
once a year i don't know if they still
do this they've sort of
left the faith but they have this thing
which they use at midnight mass and
easter called an aspergillium and it
looks like a baby's rattle
and you put it in water and it has holes
in the round head
and it fills with holy water and then
you can
fling holy water great distances
uh with this thing and
so one day back in the sacristy we were
cleaning out
some things and he came up the priest
came upon this old aspergillium
and i said whoa he was about to get rid
of it and i said well i
have a use for that and he said oh what
what is your use for this my son and i
said
well i'm involved in the conjuration of
uh ozil the 11th general
of the mercuric sphere and
it's uh it's uh launched an
investigation that has made that
town unsafe for the practice of
ceremonial magic
to this day
but the the point of my story is
they needn't have worried because and i
i
don't want to step on anybody's toes but
look i'm paid to be controversial you
understand
so they needn't have worried because
at least for this lumpen irishman
uh it didn't work no matter how much
rosemary i burned no matter how many
wax sigils were formed no matter how
many
uh even more peculiar things were
undertaken
uh it didn't seem to cut the mustard
and then around the time that i was
14 or so i i had many
obsessions and my life seems ruled by
obsession
and at some point i became aware that
there was a book at the library
that they didn't want me to read this
was when i was somewhat younger
and they didn't want me to read this
book and the librarian
who was friends with my mother had been
told if he asks for this book
don't let him have it so i not only
determined to read the book
i determined to read every book the
author had ever written
and the book was brave new world
which i don't know how many of you have
read it it wouldn't stir a small
wind these days but it did involve all
the women did wear
these prophylactic some kind of i never
quite understood what it was but it's
some kind of birth control kit that they
wore
on the belt and of course people were
grown in vats
and had very free sex and so forth and
so on
it was an interesting book but then i
started reading
the author aldous huxley and i read
chrome yellow and i read anti-k and i
read after
many a summer dies the swan and i read
eighth in essence and
some of these things were like
screenplays and some were comedies of
british manners i kept hoping we'd get
back to the prophylactic
belt thing
and instead eventually i came upon
the doors of perception and
read this book and it was like it had
never entered my mind
the concept of drugs
intoxication information from
reflection of that sort i mean the whole
thing was just
completely puzzling to me and i can
remember
following my mother around the kitchen
of our
suburban home saying if one
tenth of what this guy is saying is true
this is the most amazing thing in the
world
well now we know that that's a very
mild book very limited in its claims i
mean
he talks about staring at the folds of
his trousers
and thinking about hildegard von bingen
and
it's basically presented as a thought
thing and
most of you look like you're probably
not old enough to remember but there was
a point in the evolution of
awareness about the psychedelic
experience where the way people
did it is they piled up art books
favorite recordings foods perfumes
and then they would get loaded and then
they would look at the art books eat the
orange smell the perfume
it's not a bad it's not a bad idea
[Music]
but uh that that was the clue
to me that there was something going on
and i was as i said i was about 14 and i
had
a lot ahead of me before i really took
my first
trip and i was trying to figure it out
shopping in the in the supermarket of
ideas of the time
reading camus reading nietzsche reading
sartre
and all these people are a huge downer
as any of you
know who've read them i mean the entire
tone of modernity
is just one big downer after another
you know if it's not hana rent on the
triviality of evil well then it's
carl jasper's on something else or
sartre
and it's just horrible horrible stuff
well so
i i became aware through huxley that
there was this other possibility
and and i and huxley always wrote about
the psychedelic experience
as a branch of the mystical quest what
he called the perennial philosophy and
so i started reading
both the scholars of mysticism such as
evelyn underhill
and william
james varieties of the religious
experience and so forth and so on and i
started reading the primary sources
teresa of avila thomas trahearne
jacob burma what's the singing not
hildegard von
all of these people and and i got the
idea
that there was this experience but
i couldn't find it i couldn't find it in
uh you know on my knees at the church
for hour after hour i mean i found
various forms of existential boredom at
infinitum
but actual and i would sit in nature
and i would hyperventilate and i would
do all these things well the juice just
wasn't coming
well to make a long story short
eventually
like lots and lots of people and by my
own personal
route i found my way to these things
and they are to my mind
astonishing worthy of taking
risks for because
they work i think to some degree
it's true that all culture is somewhat
unfriendly to the individual i
you know when they when their heavy arm
falls on your shoulder and they tell you
that you're going to be sent
off to some foreign hellhole to kill
people
as a young man you definitely suddenly
get the notion
that culture is not your friend
uh but perhaps you know if you're a 12
year old boy in an amazonian
tribe and they announce that now it's
time
for the two-week abandonment in the
woods
from which if you live to tell the tale
you'll become a full member of society
i'm not sure those kids greet that with
the leap of joy
in their hearts it's like oh my god now
this
we knew it was coming
i went through rites of passage like
that that were
excruciating where i grew up in
western colorado you weren't a real man
unless
sometime between 12 and 16 you
killed an elk
hunting season every october was an
excuse
for this insane rite of passage and
my father was an unquestioning
inhabitant of his culture and so this
was always in front of me
and when i was i guess when i was 12 i
went the first time i didn't get
anything
the second year we went out and
and you know my father i'm sure had no
idea what a what a
wilted pansy i was
in this situation because i had hid it
from my mom and i
i was concerned about all kinds of
things and
and eventually this situation arose
where they put me up on this point
and gave me a gun and said if anything
came
by to blow it away and
uh you know by god
this thing you know chose to
sacrifice itself as far as i could tell
i mean it did not behave at all like elf
behave it basically just
came out of the woods stood still
i pulled down on it closed my eyes
prayed there was an enormous noise
when i opened my eyes there was nothing
whatsoever to be
seen i felt an enormous relief
that this thing had escaped and
walked over to find it dead as a doorman
and you know the oak leaves
dipped in the blood the cup of blood the
whole thing i mean i couldn't believe
how atavistic this stuff
was however i never had to please my
father again
i was home free everything was forgiven
from that moment on but it brought home
to me
how uncomfortable culture
is and and always has been
i think i've always been
sort of a knowledge freak i mean i was a
very
weird kid i knew i was weird when it was
happening but now that i have a 15 year
old son
and watch how he does it i realized how
absolutely weird i was and how alarming
i must have been to my parents
and i was i was not
socially adaptable at all because i
had bad eyes and poor coordination
and i was very easily intimidated and
like you know the story of my
early schooling was in a town of only
1200 people
i was able to find 1700
different ways to get from school to my
house
in order to avoid being pounced upon
by roving cannibal bands of my
peers who had sworn
to get me and they never got me
it was astonishing and
is that new york no no this was some cow
town in western colorado
and the other thing i discovered early
on and maybe this is
too psychotherapeutic to waste time on
was but that i could hold them at bay
with story
and essentially i became like the
the king's jester you know i became
and then i could hang out with these
lumbering
lumpen people because i i was always
willing to verbally outrage
and say crazy things i mean like one of
my
things that really got me a lot of
points with the tough guys was
i could stand up in class and very
rapidly speak sentences
into which i could occasionally drop
obscenities but you just couldn't quite
hear it
but the kids could hear it but the
teacher couldn't and
it was this
[Music]
so so that was my scene but in terms of
the relationship to knowledge
i just i love it's what william blake
said you know
he said attend the minute particulars
and and that's what's interesting i
think is
[Music]
the details of the distinctions among
things i mean that's why i was a
butterfly collector an
art historian a tibetan art hound
a rainforest botany person because what
it's all about is
the incredible variety
of morphological expression in the world
now i suppose a buddhist would recognize
this as a serious
sansaric hang up you know that i
love the texture of the
apparent visible world
[Music]
you